c'est
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir
je me suis mise à l'aise aussi un
[Applaudissements]
d'être parmi vous ce soir est de pouvoir
présenter mon sujet en live
quel avenir
pour le travail
suis-je la personne la mieux placée pour
parler de ce sujet d'une cape d'une
importance capitale pour
l'épanouissement de l'humain
quelles questions
à venir
travail
tiens tiens
travaille-t-on pour l'avenir
à l'avenir le libérateur serait-il
impérativement le travail
travaille-t-on pour préparer l'avenir
ne sachant pas de quoi sera fait
l'avenir faut-il travailler dur pour le
découvrir ou dès à présent
faut-il se mettre au travail pour
l'avenir
voyons voili voilou prenons le taureau
par les cornes
commençons par définir le travail pour
preuve je vais faire travailler notre
allié commun google
google qu'est ce que le travail
qui sous je peux te proposer plusieurs
définitions du travail je suis preneuse
google
activités de l'homme appliquée à la
production à la création à l'entretien
de quelque chose
travail manuel
intellectuelle
deux
activités professionnelles régulière et
rémunéré vivre de son travail
3 toute occupation toute activité
considérée comme une charge les enfants
ça donne bien du travail etc etc
comme tout travail mérite salaire je
dois payer google
et voilà l'effet que cette question
provoque en moi ma tête a commencé à
vagabonder à danser la valse à rêver
je me suis alors dit dissous au stop
pose toi
arrête toi quelques minutes j'ai alors
pris mon téléphone et j'ai contacté
l'organisateur un des organisateurs de
cet événement et je lui ai demandé s'il
y avait un autre thème qui serait
peut-être plus facile pour moi a traité
pas que je ne sache pas quoi dire au
contraire
mais parce que ce que j'ai à partager
peut paraître décalé est complètement
hors norme
car je suis moi même une personne hors
cadre qu'on ne peut pas mettre dans une
boîte
dont la folie pousse à créer et imaginer
des solutions dignes d'un film de
fiction ou d'une comédie par moments
l'organisateur m'a proposé de choisir le
thème que je souhaitais vous avez vu ce
que ma folie propose on ne peut pas me
résister et tissus obtient toujours ce
qu'elle veut
j'ai finalement réfléchit à tête reposée
et julie envoyait un message en lui
disant je que je gardais ce thème mais
que j'allais le faire à ma sauce
avant d'aller dans le fond du sujet
permettez moi de partager avec vous un
extrait d'un livre qui sortira
prochainement
le réveil sonne à à 5h45 tous les jours
de la semaine je tendis la main pour
repérer mon téléphone posé sur ma table
de nuit etc ou pas cette sonnerie atroce
qui indiquait le point de départ d'une
autre journée d'angoise je soupire est
une fois de plus et fini par me dire
intérieurement je vais y arriver
mais je savais que je me mentais depuis
plusieurs années je détestais maintenant
ce travail qui m'avait pourtant aidé à
me relever à un moment de ma vie je
haïsse et cette routine j'avais la
nausée lorsque je pensais aux journées
identique qui se répétait sans fin je
mis un pied au sol puis le deuxième
malgré moi j'avais besoin de ce salaire
pour vivre voilà ce qui me motivait
l'argent pour payer mes factures mais
dette et faire un semblant de plaisir
aux personnes que j'aime il fallait que
je reste dans l'endroit que je détestais
aujourd'hui le plus au monde pour
continuer de vivre dignement pour ne
plus affronté cette peur qu'ils me
paralysait et m'empêchait de franchir la
ligne qui me mènerait vers cette liberté
si
recherché si convoité si proche mais en
même temps si loin dans ma tête une
liberté qui ne demandait qu'à me prendre
dans ses bras et me bercer enfin et me
mener vers cette sérénité que je sentais
au bout de mes doigts qui battait à
rompre mon coeur qui m'étourdit c'est à
chaque instant je me traînais jusqu'à la
salle de bain en ralentissant le pas le
plus longuement possible comme si je
voulais arrêter le temps je ne voulais
vraiment pas me rendre dans ces locaux
qui me terrorisait plus qu'autre chose
une terreur qui me prenaient au coeur au
ventre à la tête et me faisait passer
des journées interminables
dès que je mettais les pieds dans ses
locaux mon rituel favori pouvait
commencer
surveillez les aiguilles de la montre
pour me rendre compte du temps qui me
séparait du moment où je mettais les
pieds dehors et mme installé
confortablement dans ma voiture pour
rejoindre un lieu où je me sentais bien
et est en sécurité
la maison chaleureuse de ibra qui
m'écoutait parler pendant des heures le
jardin apaisant deux anciens qui me
rassurait sur mon avenir la terrasse
accueillante de lucelle où je pouvait
admirer le coucher de soleil pendant de
longues minutes où le moment où je
france ficelles la porte de ma maison et
que les cas l'un de mes enfants effacer
tous les tourments de la journée je
pénétrai dans la salle de bains me
mettez devant mon miroir et observer la
trajectoire des larmes qui coulaient le
long de mes joues à chaque coup les deux
larmes je devinais le chemin qu'elle
allait emprunter allait-elle couler tout
droit le long de ma joue et finir leur
promenade sur le bord de ma lèvre
supérieure ou sur la fossette de mon
menton des matins je voulais tout
simplement les dévié par le revers d'une
main tremblotante qui ne demandait plus
qu'à deux de devenir calme et sereine
chaque matin c'était le même rituel
depuis plus de deux ans
l'avenir du travail serait bien triste
avec ce récit et pourtant combien de
personnes dans les entreprises vivent ce
calvaire est ce que le travail doit se
limiter aux salaires doit se résumer à
effectuer ou une ou des tâches dans un
laps de temps précis et rentrer chez soi
vide sans âme sans avoir rien absorber
de positif de jouissif métro boulot dodo
comme on le dit en occident
j'ai essayé de demander à notre ami
google de me renseigner sur un
pourcentage de personnes et en en burn
out ou en épuisement mental lié au
travail
là j'avoue que notre allié doit se
mettre à jour parce que je n'ai
absolument rien trouvé sur la guinée
donc je vais partager avec vous des
informations que j'ai obtenus sur le net
je cite
selon l'institut national de recherche
et de sécurité
un tiers des travailleurs européens se
plaignent de problèmes de santé liés à
un travail stressant
le burn out est la deuxième maladie du
siècle après le mal de dos
la france est le deuxième pays à
consommer des antidépresseurs liée au
problème du travail la mission
parlementaire sur l'épuisement
professionnel en 2016 bon google ne m'a
pas donné de chiffres plus récents a
révélé que l'extrapolation d'une veille
mis en place dans les régions montrerait
que 490 mille cas d'épuisement
professionnel par an c'est à dire que 2%
de la population active à partir de 15
ans y compris les jeux les chômeurs
serait atteinte du burn out waouh je
mens n'arrête à sa conf issus nous at il
pas dit choisi un travail que tu aimes
et tu n'auras pas travailler un seul
jour de ta vie combien de personne sur
cette terre sont parfois contraintes
affaires de travail un travail qu'elle
n'aime pas ceci ne devrait pas être la
norme
chacun devrait avoir la liberté de
choisir
parce que qui dit travail devrait
normalement parler de liberté
d'épanouissement de bonheur au travail
mais nous sommes loin de cette réalité
et cette réalité est d'autant plus
éloignée que les lieux de travail
devrait être un havre de paix pour les
travailleurs puisque sans conteste il y
place leclerc de l'entente puisqu'il ne
le placent à leur domicile une salle de
détente une salle de sport une section
de soutien psychologique les rencontres
entre collègues en dehors du travail
l'organisation de team building et
cetera et cetera
mesdames et messieurs les employeurs
pensez-y
la norme devrait être aussi la
reconnaissance et la valorisation des
travailleurs vis-à-vis de leur
hiérarchie
le management par le haut par
l'excellence savoir s'arrêter et
féliciter le travail bien fait les
conséquences positives à savoir
pécuniaire promotionnelles cette
reconnaissance peut pousser à libérer
des talents un soupçon et de certains
travailleurs
mesdames et messieurs les patrons
d'entreprises pensez-y
nous évoluons dans un monde incertain
rapide disruptif il faut savoir donc
être agile et pouvoir s'adapter à ces
changements
au risque de perdre en efficacité et en
productivité
je ne devais pas être aujourd'hui ici
avec vous mon intervention devait se
faire virtuellement mais j'ai pu me
libérer et jeu et je suis donc là j'ai
tenu néanmoins à faire mon introduction
par vidéo pour vous montrer non
seulement l'importance d'être agile et
de rester en actions pour obtenir un
résultat positif mais je souhaitais
surtout vous montrer que nous devons
absolument changer nos façons de faire
nous devons nous transformer
j'aurais bien pu décliner tout
simplement l'invitation des
organisateurs parce que mon emploi du
temps ne me permet pas d'être présente
j'ai choisi de m'adapter et de faire le
travail qu'ils m'ont confié et qu'est ce
que la plupart et c'est ce que fait la
plupart des entreprises occupent deux
ans maintenant avec l'apparition de
lakovic elles ont dû s'adapter le trait
de travail s'est développé dans
plusieurs pays est devenu la norme dans
certains pays occidentaux
aujourd'hui nous pouvons travailler de
n'importe quel endroit pas besoin de se
déplacer
mais pour cela il faut un minimum de
conscience professionnelle
mesdames et messieurs les salariés
pensez-y pour que les employeurs y pense
l'avenir du travail c'est cela aussi se
transformer et rester en action et
lorsqu'on parle de transformation dans
le monde professionnel il faut y penser
d'abord en amont en effet nous assistons
aujourd'hui à la disparition de certains
métiers à l'avènement d'autres
liés surtout aux nouvelles technologies
le digital le numérique
il y a donc nécessité de revoir le
système éducatif et la formation pour
permettre aux générations futures de
pouvoir répondre aux nouvelles exigences
du marché du travail plusieurs
entreprises sont aujourd'hui confrontées
à des difficultés énormes pour pouvoir
dénicher des profits pour certains
postes ils sont obligés d'aller les
chercher dans d'autres prix très
lointain ils n'ont pas su elles n'ont
pas su se préparer à l'avenir et
préparer à l'avenir c'est être à
l'écouté justement de ce qui se passe
dans l'environnement dans lequel on
évolue c'est préparer ses ressources
humaines à pouvoir s'adapter à cet
environnement
c'est les former pour les transformer et
les valoriser c'est les préparer à
répondre aux exigences de leurs clients
qui sont devenus des influenceurs actif
et qui ont le pouvoir de les faire
briller ou les éteindre en un seul poste
en un seul clic et en quelques secondes
quel avenir pour le travail
l'avenir
à venir proche ou lointain
l'avenir doit d'abord se conjuguer au
présent le présent à couches dites ont
de l'avenir
les défis sont nombreux
le challenge est énorme il y a tellement
de choses à dire mais moi j'ai choisi
cet angle
mais les solutions existent et ces
solutions doivent être pensés par des
femmes et des hommes qui travaillent
en vous remerciant
mesdames et messieurs les travailleurs
merci à vous